so lots of stuff happen I was not going
to give up I'm going to win in spite of
and because of what makes success is do
a lot more than what is asked of you
nothing anymore is bad it's all
something I could learn from grow from
and need to change from because I don't
want that to happen again right it's a
story I've never told anybody this
happen is happening this is a world
premiere of this story yes welcome
everybody I'm here sitting with the
legendary Ivana Chubbuck who was the
acting coach for the stars thank you for
allowing us into your home today for
this interview absolutely my pleasure
I've been diving into your world for a
long time you you struck me because I
love how you try to tie in the realness
you want actors to win you want them to
have an emotional scene they have to tie
into something from their past so they
feel emotional to go and deliver so
you're not you're not faking it it's a
real story mm-hmm and what I'm super
curious about is how can we apply that
to the business world the
entrepreneurial world or being a better
coach or being a better communicator
because at the end of the day it's about
communication right transferring emotion
and so maybe it's a starting point using
me as a guinea pig so what I'll do a lot
of is is coaching entrepreneurs so I'm
doing a workshop here tonight in LA
we're gonna have 90 people showing up
people gonna ask me their business
problems I want to reach them in a way
that will make them take action and not
just give the practical tips and
knowledge but move them can we apply
your technique to that you it's the
human experience and basically my
technique is based in behavioral science
psychology and cultural anthropology
which is the history of mankind and the
human experience and why we do the
things that we do that never really
changes our the dynamic of our needs are
always the same and they're universally
the same you all have the same issues
with their abandonment issues for
they're not good enough
feelings of being like we're trying to
prove proofs ourselves we're getting our
power back or the same fears and
insecurities that exist all over the
world and what makes culture is how we
manifest those needs the basic human
needs
so can what I do work for
entrepreneurship kind of work for
relationships of any kind whether it's a
business communication or communication
that you're putting something on the
stage it's the same dynamic that we're
dealing with the same concepts that
we're dealing with so one of the things
that I think is really important is that
finding what it is that we love to do
because if we're going to talk about the
in terms of coaching people in the
business world and being entrepreneur or
any version of the business world even
being a part of somebody else's company
you have to love what you do if you
don't love what you do then you are
going to watch the clock and it's going
to go very very slow you're not going to
want to work those extra hours or have
that impulse an inspiration to do more
than what you're asked to do because
what makes success is do a lot more than
what is asked of you so you have to
figure out first what what's my love
it's right what is the thing that I I
really want to do with my life one of
the things I would start off with in
terms of like your world is to have
people write a journal of what it is
that I want to be successful who I want
to be successful for and why so it would
be in terms of you know I want to be
successful for first thing that comes to
your head you helping entrepreneurs no
person's name of why you want to do it
person's ain't mom dad so for somebody
else yeah why do I need to be successful
for myself comes to mind but that's not
the answer you want could be okay
okay and why yourself that's the next of
it because the the power of Y yeah this
is really important okay why do you want
to help entrepreneurs well I'm trying to
do something for myself
why yourself now kept many levels of
things it could be yourself because you
felt like in my case myself might it
might be the answer because my father
had to give up so much of what his love
was and his passion was and he knew what
his passion was but he couldn't he had
seven kids so he couldn't follow that
passion and so for me I need to do for
myself would be I then boil it down to
it was really for my father so you
couldn't do but I'm gonna do this for
you and so that becomes very important
why I did this for you because you
didn't weren't able do this for yourself
as you were an incredible father you
were an amazing man you were brilliant
and and very creative I want to be able
to say it wasn't for not that you were
had to take care of a bunch of kids and
then died fairly early in his life
before he could even see my success but
I but but but it doesn't matter even
though he's passed away I'm still doing
it for him
and my why is because I want to make up
for the fact that he couldn't do it for
himself and then I also want my daughter
to be able to find her way to being able
to see me as someone that she respects
and looks up to because I didn't respect
my mother
so like the female in my life but you
see how the wise and the psychology of
just stuff which I would ask an actor to
do in terms of playing a role why do you
need to play this role and what is this
going to benefit you and empower you to
do and you solve in your own life and so
the idea is I am all about empowering
you know my actors to make choices that
take the victim out of being victim
so because usually in drama something
happens to you that you have to like you
hit bottom and you have to explore some
kind of
Adventure it helps you to fix that drama
your kids been kidnapped
you've been someone's chasing after you
robbed a bank and you're only a cut I
mean it's like some kind of thing that
you're trying to solve and then using
your personalizations that allow you to
find how you can solve something in your
own life so that's how we find it so the
idea is for yourself and I'm gonna ask
you now yeah why yeah the two things
that come to mind one I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur I I slayed it
myself my first business insulated
myself was struggling making 300 bucks a
month afraid to tell my friends that I
was struggling said I'm hustling and
living the entrepreneur life or
meanwhile 20 bucks for pizza and beer
was too much for me and I just was
working so hard and was not getting
results and I felt the most worthless as
a human that I've ever felt and so I
don't I go back to that pain and just
eating beans for lunch every day and
just a struggle of doing that I want to
try to make the world better by having
entrepreneurs not have to go through
that same thing and give them some kind
of answers that will allow them to be
able to avoid the the hurt the tragedy
that you felt one side your heart that
you really as a man because of men feel
more the pressure to prove that they can
it's just the biology of being a man
like I have to run my cave and and you
know and provide for my family and and
it's just again the nature of being the
man versus the woman who creates life
and then is biologically to be a
nurturer so it became hyper
necessary for you to do this because you
were where did you start trying to be an
entrepreneur with all the the bees and
stuff give me give me like how many
years ago those 19 years 19 was when I
started that company mm-hmm I had
tendencies for entrepreneurship before
but 19 was when I Fishes started that
I'm 38 now so almost 20 years I'm 39 in
May so
okay so how long before you figured out
that maybe it's not about me becoming an
entrepreneur but it's about me coaching
entrepreneurs why did that revelation
happen and what was the trigger for that
so after I sold my business so I
struggled the beginning I built it up I
sold it I got asked to start doing a
whole bunch of speaking as a young
entrepreneur success story and I was
flattered and I said sure why not I'll
do it and in in the back of my head is
my mom's voice who would always say if
you have the ability to help then you
have the responsibility to help so you
just told me something your mother's the
reason why you're doing okay so we fold
it down to and it's just like pulling
people and said like the the same world
that this is what I do with actors yeah
it's like it's for yourself and now we
get down to the baseline is your mother
your mother's say okay great that you
were accomplished and you became an
entrepreneur the bean days are over
um but you have more to give and you
wanted to make your mom proud and you
wanted to make her be right and her
assumption of your abilities and your
talents because the giver is often a
teacher has to be selfless but there's
such a joy to me when people say did you
ever miss acting I said I don't miss it
at all because what I get out of
empowering other people to greatness
makes me feel like I was the one that
was able to do that so it makes me feel
ten times more empowered then I feel
that even my clients you know because of
I see how people respond to and their
own you know light that glows around
their accomplishments and and and
utilizing and this is the basis of my
technique utilizing your your pain your
traumas your insecurities as gifts I say
instead of self-destructing with that
information use it to fuel your your
your your ability to overcome and win
whatever it is you want so first you
have to figure out in terms of dealing
with you talking what do you want to do
to some my sister what she decided that
she want
just make more money so she she became
she was a social worker and he became go
into marketing went back to school to
marketing but she never loved it so she
was never successful with it passion and
love of what you do will make you and I
by accident because it's gravy assay if
you love what you do it doesn't matter
if you make a lot of money so but what
happens is the next thing you know is
suffer knees coming to you I remember
the big day where I was able to not have
to balance my checkbook was that but I
wasn't thinking I'm not gonna do this to
make money I was thinking I love doing
what I do I love breaking down a script
I love helping people solve their their
personal issues through their characters
that they're playing on the screen and
therefore helping the world that watches
them because I have that domino effect
it's like I work with one person but
that one person shows millions of people
and the choices we make air about
empowerment through pain so we're not
just so so that's that's our message
that goes subliminally through the movie
or TV show or play that they're doing
and therefore we're touching so many
people's lives internationally by doing
that and so that is something that I
love doing so much that when money
started coming it was incidental I mean
it's lovely I have a Ferrari in my
driveway you know but the point is it's
not about that and I perfectly love my
Dodge Dart right and it was totally
rusted out it and I couldn't see the
ground the videos you were driving a
line and in Michigan that was like where
I grew up was like those are the kinds
of cars that I would drive and I brought
it out here my little jalopy and I was
and because it really was about finding
my love and first I think when I was
doing acting came out here to act it was
time went by so slow because I didn't
love it I'd like the art of it but I
didn't love the being the person who was
the actor and I found that time went by
really slow and when I was helping my
friends with choices which is what
actors do with each other time went by
really fast
to the point where it became where I
just said you I don't really want to act
anymore but because I like that time
goes by so fast whenever I'm enjoying
something whatever it is you know
someplace to play tennis or you know
wherever it is that they do it's like
when time goes by fast
it's that means you love you love it but
and I also find that whatever you love
you probably have a gift for hmm it's
interesting that's just the psyche of
like what we love who doesn't love
doesn't have to be the obvious loves
loves could be something that you just
like you know like accounting you know
accounting because you like the the
organization of numbers and numbers are
there's so much numbers can do and
numbers that the world is made up of
numbers and math and math is so
fascinating to me and all the things
math can do and all that the equations
that can create all the scientific you
know realities that we have and the
technology that we're even here sitting
here being able to talk and communicate
with the world that we do all comes from
math and so the accountant loves math
and so he's gonna be good at that and it
doesn't without judgments like you can
only love things like be on camera or
love architecture or writing a book or
or whatever it's like without judgment
finding out what it is that you love
what's probably what your what your gift
is to and knowing what your gift is it
is going to is one of the rarest things
that people have people go to the grave
not knowing what their passion is and
what their gift is was just was handed
in as opposed to trying to put the
square peg in the round hole which is a
lot of people do I want to be this and
I'm just going to keep even though
everything keeps struggling
it's everything becomes really difficult
because she's just trying so hard and
things aren't happening for you when I
was first came out here I was starting
to get acting jobs but I was getting
writing jobs and they were coming easily
but I was just
my acting that's it I don't want to be a
writer you know I want to be you know
I'm an actress you know and that's what
I'm gonna be like chiseling through
trying to get that audition trying to
make me beg it should be this is what I
might to do this is my my my my destiny
but the things like writing my book
that's been translated in many languages
soon to be many more it's really
interest Mongolians will be the end
about Greek Mandarin Chinese is already
and simple Chinese what's the first
thing which you got translated into
Spanish Spanish okay make sense yeah and
that was me being swimming in a pool and
Mexican do you know resort and just
chatting away with somebody who is at
the pool to happen to be a publisher
translated books English into Spanish
and it was one of those but that's what
I'm saying these energy no it's not that
the energy you whatever if you find what
you love the energy will find people
will attract because the world is made
our bodies are made up of a two-thirds
water which is is the best conductor of
electricity so were those people that
feel that connection with each other
it's electrical impulses that are
connecting that it from the psyche they
are connecting that we both have similar
issues and a commonality opinion and all
that kind of stuff that just in the air
the transcends language and and
ideologies and and and and religion
whatever and so I attracted that and
that those who can't those stories we
said you must have a great agent to say
I don't have one I don't have one that
puts it out there I have one that makes
deals come to me but I tracked it you
know because it's something I love to do
is something that I love doing when I
was a kid I was someone who couldn't
talk to people so I couldn't express
myself I literally couldn't talk I felt
that anything I had to say was too
stupid I would write I'd write things to
be accepted hand them to people and they
liked me because I was funny you know so
I wrote funny stuff so it's like but so
finding my gift even I thought was
acting but I did when I finally just let
them someone told me this you've got to
let the world give you your answers
stuff's going to come at you and you got
to be open to it you be open to
maybe this is it try it out oh this is
great so you know I love this story okay
okay so I had he's still my friend a
very good friend who is a nuclear
physicist but when I am in high school
and he was a very very talented jazz
musician went to Berklee School of Music
and he worked and he actually got played
with Dizzy Gillespie and we were talking
about he was saying he was hitting it
and not loving it so he decided to do
exactly that
he said let's find out what it is that
I'd love to do cuz I don't know what it
is so he went back to college he's 30
years old when this happened so it was
like 10 years of doing this other stuff
and successfully and he took all
different kinds of classes so literature
journalism their history all these
things and nothing was hitting him but
his math courses were and then he says
I'm gonna do some science science
classes and I'm bigger than this they
start doing some physics classes and and
said I love this and he couldn't get it
eat it eat it up with nothing this guy's
really good talented musician and he
dropped all of that and became a very
very heralded a nuclear physicist with
many many things that he's discovered
and he travels the world with and
talking to thousands of other scientists
and he was just the guy who was who
thought what his dream was was something
that was what he was good at but it
wasn't necessarily his passion and it's
love but he figured it out they became
open to it there's all different kinds
of ways of being open for me it was
being open to I was doing something to
support my acting but then it turned out
to be something that I was I just really
enjoyed doing it and I and I'm and I'm
good at it
and as a gift you know and and so doing
that journal I need to
I need to be successful for you here who
does you be successful for because and
then what you find that is like the
bottom line of why you need to be and
then I really love and then you would
just keep writing like automatic writing
and see what comes up
then you figure out what you love these
for you where does that find its way so
how do I take my love and make it a
business and whatever that is you help
people so give so give me for example
something that I think you found your
way you this is your this is your life I
can see you talk about it and you you're
a bright light shines around you so when
you're talking to these people you have
to help them figure out what their love
is you have to see what do you love to
do what is it something that this is no
matter how silly or weird it isn't find
a way to them explore their ideas of how
to put that into play and make money
doing it also in terms of communication
with people exploring there like I said
look at you and make it about you
when you go into a job interview for
example and you sit there and talk about
yourself at nauseam it's like being at a
party and you're talking to someone
that's talking about themselves what
happens you want to walk away when the
person is asking you a whole bunch of
questions and you're answering and then
they're offering some of their stuff
about their life but and then going back
to questions what happens it creates an
interplay a real dialogue and an
investment in your answers I want to
know your answers I will be a better
person from your answers it makes the
other person feel special so that is the
same in the in terms of making an
employee or your employees feel that
they want to do extra work for you work
harder for you be a support player that
makes them work harder and then
therefore your business becomes more
successful your people that work for you
have to be really happy campers the
people that want
want them to hire you you want to make
them feel like I'm routine you're not
hiring me we're gonna help each other
this is gonna be a team a team you know
effort it's a story I've never told
anybody this is happening is happening
this is a world premiere of this story
yes when I first came out here about a
year to end I've one of my things that I
wanted to do is comedy and I got to know
my writing just like you know being work
ethic is a really important part of
being a successful person and so I would
write a whole bunch of like short
stories and write write things for
magazines and send it to them and
whether they hired me or not sometimes
even sometimes it didn't but I would
write I had stacks of stuff that never
got sold but that's what you do one
person particularly responded to one of
the funny stories I wrote who it's a
very important comedy producer and
writer and so he invited me to go to a
party where people like Steve Martin and
coming to major comedy people were there
I was so intimidated I said so I said
I'm gonna do a little experiment I don't
have much to tell these people these
people have lifes I'm a young girl who
has very little experience to do
anything I come from Michigan was just
like you know they're you know
provincial well little Midwestern kind
of town so I didn't have a lot of life
experience and so I I said what they're
gonna ask a lot of questions and then
off their answers I'm gonna ask more
questions so there's like three hours of
many different people and just asking
questions and that's all I did was ask
questions and responded are like really
listening to their questions their
answers because there's questions based
on their answers so the next day my
friend they've been friends and you know
the comedy writer producer kiss me what
did you do last night and I said what do
you mean and he said everybody fell in
love with you they said you were the
most scintillating conversationalist and
they so enjoyed your conversation they
really liked you I never said one thing
about myself there's all questions
I was a scintillating conversationalist
that they wanted to spend more time with
so I think that's that that the the
moral of the story is don't make it
about you it's boring to other people
people love talking about themselves and
and and if you truly are a person that
should be an entrepreneur or somebody
who's successful you truly have to be
interested in other people if all you
are interested in yourself you're not
going to get the team it's always a team
that makes success your team will not
support you because I say you don't care
about me anyway but if you really are
invested in and the other person's
knowledge experiences humor giving them
you banter like this enjoying a funny
conversation people want to spend time
with you people want to be a part of
your world people want you to be a part
of theirs and and so I always say take
your eyes off of you and put them on the
other person actors do this all the time
it's a real problem we're actors made it
all about their inner work and they're
exploring their inner work and they said
no it's all about getting a reaction
because then what their reaction is just
going to determine what you're gonna do
next and then they feel that they're
that they're special enough that you're
their answers mean something enough to
you for you to be truly listening so
this example I always give to people I
said if I go to a party and someone
comes up to you and he says Evan Evan
good to see you so um so what's up
what's going on and then they keep
walking right okay so how does that make
you feel they asked you a question but
didn't stay to listen to the answer
because they really didn't care to hear
the answer it makes you feel awful it
makes you feel like a small little
invisible person you know that doesn't
count and makes you it makes you feel
bad that you think that's the same
concept it's like someone who's asked
questions without caring what the
answers are truly care about that the
answer deciding to
the CEO of like major major Chinese
company yesterday and he said what he he
was telling me about one of the first
like big jobs he got was that he was
they were asking questions and kept
throwing some stuff back and he noticed
and just a tiny corner of the room of
this guy's office that he was being
interviewed was a picture of a very
famous racecar
you know driver and it was very kind of
like heralded as a in terms of its being
and the really great frame so clearly
something very important to this guy so
he brings up as here you know with with
their as they're winding it down he said
I bet you I could beat you on the
racetrack okay
and the guy says I take you up on that
okay because he didn't but you did he
just saw that peripherally as something
that was on his death this is like them
saying be interested right truly be
curious truly care about other people
and be fascinated that the people are
all living their lives and trying to
survive and how are they doing it and
the answers that they give also give you
answers to help you to so this is not
just a trick it will make your life
happier and more satisfying to be able
to like have real true communication
with somebody it takes a lowliness out
of life wow there's so much that you sit
there the past few stories so many
jumping-off points you try to figure out
where I want to go next to this it's
amazing you know the thing that's coming
to my mind is is another thing that I'm
struggling with that that I'd super
appreciate your insights on that tie
into everything you've been talking
about which is around I am afraid to get
famous because I tie it to ego hmm and
I'm curious how either you deal with it
personally because now you've you've
become the star maker but also people
you work with some of them wanted and
crave it and like they need to be the in
the limelight but for someone who is
on the other side humble humble is very
very important okay but he goes also
important okay
relying on the ego from a place of I
needed and crave it is the pathology
it's a pathology Jay um having ego and
feeling good about yourself is really
important they say there's a healthy
part to ego so if you're someone that is
afraid of the ego being going to the
place that becomes a disease or as it is
a disease it's Darcis ism is basically
what's that school you know and is is
that you the fact that you are cognizant
of it it means that's not going to ever
be an issue for you enjoy your and enjoy
your accomplishments and it's really
important for people to get I did that
or sometimes what I'll do is I'll tell
people it's like they'll do something
really wonderful off of what I said and
I'll go god I'm good but they know that
that's coming from a humble place sure
it's affect you did that was what made
me feel good about myself so I basically
was that joke made it be about their
accomplishment but our team ship
regarding that and and to be able to say
that brag but to be able to acknowledge
your accomplishments like when I said I
had all these books in different
languages but that was like four years
writing this book I have I want the
unhealthy part of the ego I have the ego
of a lot of hard work coming to pass and
creating with incredible results so when
I said that did you feel that I was an
egocentric person when I don't know I
don't know yeah because I was coming
from the healthy part of ego ego it
doesn't have to be tempered when you're
the kind of person that you are you're a
humble guy so the thing is that you said
with you what I would do is stop being
afraid of stuff because anything that
has is attached to fear is going to
create fear
a fair fearful results so you had to
censor yourself and any version of
censorship is going to stop you so I'm
afraid that's gonna be too egocentric so
I'm not going to do that then you just
miss an opportunity to have really great
impulses based on a healthy ego right
and and and I think that people have to
like start loving themselves a little
bit more and realizing that I accomplish
this good for me good works really hard
I earned this and the idea that the
unhealthy part the people that have the
unhealthy egos they don't know they
don't know they're never gonna fix
something because they don't think they
have it all the people that you know
that are very like ego-centered
narcissists right do they think they are
I think they're the most giving brains
very charitable grateful people on the
planet and they that's it so if you
worry about it these you're not that
right and and so stop worrying about it
because all that's gonna do is create
stoppage never censorship is the enemy
of forward motion and success in
anything you have to put that on my wall
mmm I like that one it's a good insert
if ik it's a great one for you too it's
like no it's really great um over the
past couple years it didn't now me
forcing myself more into the front and
not just behind and learning that people
can actually learn from my story to help
them grow as well and so sure story it
also like this is what I do and I give
these kind of speeches is I I place out
and you remember in the book there's a I
think I'll substitution okay it's about
like substituting somebody else that you
love and you care about yes for the
people that are strangers right right
acting with well you can do that and
will you have those people that are in
front of you that you're doing these
events for you place people that you
care about what I do is I place my
family you know I places my sister Linda
is right there
she over the person that kind of looks
like her my brother Joe in the third row
my my dad and the sixth row so it should
this way when I'm talking to a group I'm
really talking to individuals
I'm really looking in people's eyes and
and that's going I don't look at people
as a mess because nobody likes to feel
like they're part of a mass humanity so
I see them as specific and I talked I
talked to people I feel them and I
Intuit them and it's like so I will if
you were part of like 90 people here I
would find your face and like a Pataki
maybe tap that sentence go to you the
second part of the second sentence would
blow that person right behind you or
whatever so cuz I'm relating to you as
if we're having a one-on-one
conversation even though it's a group I
mean I've had groups of a thousand
people you know and and it's act like so
you still can do that and people do feel
that you're doing that it's a trick that
like a lot of Las Vegas or like big
performers do is they will be able you
know place and people that they love
throughout the audience so if everybody
feels that you're singing to them and so
would you do that for the person that
you are actually talking to or just
somebody next to them you do you just
put right before what I always do
I don't know necessarily if I don't like
to be introduced okay so I'd like to sit
there or watch people come in and I say
hi it's her she's on the stage you know
and so they automatically feel you know
comfortable and familiar with me and I
want them to feel I always have a chair
like this so that it feels like I'm in a
chair that would be in someone's living
room that I get a hit my microphone
because I don't like those things that
do that because I like holding on to
something and I walk the stage and do
this stuff sometimes I go into the
audience but but I basically welcome
some men and so and then maybe some will
come in and introduce me where I'm
already been there but say I hate the
being heralded I want everybody to feel
like I just happen to have some
information you don't have but we're all
the same
equal and then so this way it's that
that and here's a well know League kind
of you know kind of introduction and it
makes me feel weird because that ego
thing you're talking about
so is that censorship no no because I've
created a fixer so so they can still say
all that but I've already proved they
don't have that kind of ego so I don't
need to censor myself so the first
couple of times before I figured that
out was I was censoring myself so the
first couple of beats of doing the
speech I was not very good because
censorship does create fearful results
which are stoppage so I had to find a
solvent always all things that like our
problems are opportunities for to solve
them because opportunities for solution
so I found a solution that helped me be
able to be in the room and that feel
like I don't like meself in Brandeis I
hate it you know so they can still say
all that stuff but I've already proven
to myself that I'm not because I sat
there watching everybody come in you
know and waving to them and say how you
doin today it was like making a joke or
whatever and playing with people was it
as you're coming in and then and then
while I'm doing that I'm also kind of
connecting them to people that I know so
who you talk to but it's just even if
it's you you have to be presented and
that's just the way it is and that's the
way your story goes it's like you come
in and you immediately you start to this
is what actors do on auditions you make
your substitution choices you just kind
of boom boom boom and to make it one
person to make it easier so you make it
your wife and your wife is biggest she's
a friendly face and she wants you to
succeed and it's sexy too so it creates
this like connection together wrong
thing in the front of the same thing
sexuality is is just your body part of
your okay okay you know it's just take
biology biology and the most important
chakra is your is the sex chakra because
it's creation the energy of creation
so it's not the third eye it's not the
heart chakra but it really is the number
one chakra is your sex chakra because
and that's what because of this creation
but that's why people who lose sports
are told not to have sex before a big
event because that energy needs to be
restored into the game and so it's that
so it's a very powerful thing but if you
use your wife and put her out there but
you say made you smile and I said yeah
wife out there as all of some people go
I know him I want to be I want I want to
have him to be my friend on so many
levels you know so and doesn't read it
all sexual it just reads it like I have
a three-dimensional connection with you
my hurts with you my intellect with you
like that is with you and my body's with
you so it's like all the things that
make up the human animal science all
right all science you need to bring a
different energy just Mike's workshop
I'm liking that because you don't even
know when I did the this I did an
exercise where I taught chemistry
exercise which I can't do it in this
kind of environment but I did in the
small group of CEOs from this company
and it just was like I said you connect
to people part of the substitution and
part of its commonality of pain so you
don't feel uncomfortable but your own
stories of course I think you already
know that your stories that when I asked
you you were very open about like your
your struggles and how much you hated
them and you still remember him to this
day but then we talked about your mom
and one of the so and she said to you
you're here to help people
and that became the thing
ding-ding-ding-ding moment of that's
really why you're doing it because you
love your mom your premiere product of
her then she gave you something that
helped you understand your gift and your
passion and that's what moms are
supposed to do you know and so so so the
idea of connecting to people is really
really important that we are friends
here I will feel comfortable in telling
you my stuff you can be feel comfortable
and feeling your stuff there's one of
the things that I do to get people to
open up
they often talk about my own stuff I
told you about my father and that kind
of made you start thinking about your
mom okay so even though you didn't say
it right away I knew I was inspiring
that thought process so you're not
necessarily creating an actual dialogue
with these people and when you're
speaking to them however you are because
they are answering and their stories mmm
they keep it personal be open about
revealing things that most we would be
scared to reveal take shame out of your
stories take doubt out of your stories
take it this is how I become this person
that I am today because of the things
that I've experienced all the bad and
the good they're equally is wonderful
you know so we have to look at our
survival and our being able to win in
spite of and because of our our fears
our issues our traumas that things that
happened to us that we see in spite of
and because of becomes a journey of
wealth emotional wealth because nothing
anymore is bad it's all something I
could learn from grow from and need to
change from because I don't want that to
happen again right but when it happens
again when and if it happens again and
more capable in dealing with this so I
can make it less traumatic when you're
telling the story about your dad I was I
was thinking you've got into my head but
it you actually got into my heart you
know out of my head exactly my heart and
so it's hearts in a people's hearts yeah
that's the best business thing I could
give to people yeah don't make it about
the the the the business get into their
hearts like I told you the story about
the the racecar moment right and that
was it big sir this is we're talking
about like I mean it was like something
it's just a total corporate world I mean
nothing to do with arts whatsoever and
that's what he did and he's like he
you dick you lessly successful guy who
came from very good small little class
family yeah so you mentioned that most
people die never figure out the thing
that they should be doing and you didn't
look for it so here's a look for it
gonna be open to it I've gotta do dirt
only on it you guys this is my question
because you said be open to it a lot and
so how much of it is being open and just
recognizing what's happening your
environment versus you note well like
that I think my friend Steve who who
went back to school he say I'm gonna try
every topic and see what excites me you
gotta be proactive things don't always
go knock on your door and say here's
your gift right is your passion
you got to go out and try different
things you got a you know like you'll
just think about to do the miners things
that's like excites you
I like playing tennis and so you like
playing games maybe you know creating
sometimes you know putting yourself in
an environment we take the classes and
and how to put together making video
games I don't did I call that anymore
such a world out there if you can be so
successful if that's you just love that
so much you be in that world but see if
that's something that you want to do be
part of the the making of the give the
games or being someone who sells the
games you're part of the world of it
that makes you feel that you are part of
something that you're passionate about
but I don't actually anything but things
put yourself just keep trying different
things off of kernels of things that do
that you love do you subscribe to try
anything once I do but sometimes they
can get you into trouble with values
right of course I mean and and nobody
gets hurt yeah should everybody try to
be an actor at least once no how come
this is a hard job yes I love it so much
there
you have to deal with so much rejection
you have to pull up so much stuff you
have to be like love it so much it it's
not it's not sure to bring up your your
horrible childhood issues and the thing
that your husband's abusing you because
you come from
mama station or whatever it's like you
have to love it so much that that
becomes a joy to do it I see people with
live actors and really opening to be
actors when they when I bring up that's
kind of when I help them bring up the
stuff that that allows them to really
explore character from its I was in the
arts the dark is your light and the Arts
the dark is the light and so it is when
I see it actually really wants to be an
actor and that's a passion in love they
light up when they go there but but some
people do that good but hurt and I don't
want cause hurt and pain for anybody and
I think that that's what a true actor
you nobody likes to be lied to and if
you're going to just hide behind a
character basically lying to your
audience so you're not doing anybody any
help you're not helping yourself because
you're lying to yourself you're lying to
your audience who's you know pissed off
at the fact because they felt bit feel
being lied to and so the people are told
they're honest honest truth of the
darkest darkest you know things have
happened to them through their work and
how they're trying to solve it because
my work is all about solving it the
objective I need to solve the problem
for character then how does that make
sense to my life in the personalizations
and we're all about taking the bad and
the darkness and turn it into into
devolvement and light and it's some
version of prosperity that their
spiritual prosperity emotional
prosperity actual physical prosperity
it's like it doesn't matter we need to
find a way to take that the bad energy
and turn it into positive energy and you
can do that that's what dynamic people
do the whole thing about people who are
really dynamic you really look at their
histories they've had to live some
fairly abusive histories it doesn't
necessarily have to be home environment
it could be peers being bullied I mean
so many places that things haven't then
life happens and it's how people take
that information 90% of the population
of the world takes that information of a
certain pain and fear and use it so as
information self-destruct with but the
dynamic people the world they are the
ones that take the same same exact
information that most of the population
just destroyed
you know self destruct and so close with
and it makes them and they used to say
I'm gonna win I'm gonna win and I'm
gonna you know prove you wrong or the
world wrong or these other people or the
abuser wrong and and and making the
judgments about me and and and and I'm
going to be and enjoy every damn second
approving you wrong this is gonna be fun
you know to do it and then failure
become is like okay that's another one
I'm overcoming that I'm using that path
is always an up and down you know it's
gonna be a roller coaster ride you're
going to gain something and then you're
gonna fail then you're gonna gain so
you're gonna fail but how you deal with
failure is the mark of a dynamic person
failure is to be solved we learned from
to grow from and and to explore growth
from and then the good stuff is is great
you enjoy it but you don't have to spend
that much time with it other than to say
okay how do I raise the bar I
accomplished this I want to raise the
bar so we figure out what's my next
what's the next thing my first thing was
like publish this book the first one
that was a lot of work then the next
thing was get him in different languages
then the next thing was in a more
languages and there's getting more of
teachers in schools around the world
using it's got an email today saying
that this very very important believe I
could say the most important drama
school and all of Germany that is a
government-run school which is very
important because that means it's even
more
Cayenne is now officially using my
technique awesome and my technique is
the only one that in terms of like
officially being used it's the only one
that's an official using in that
institution so it's like everybody's the
bargain I get more of those so the thing
is just like the good is not to sit with
they said obsessive here my laurels I
accomplish this you try for something
much bigger than and something's bound
to happen where you're gonna fail if
something's gonna you know say you can't
do this or someone's gonna make fun of
you or humiliate you or something like
that you have to use that as your oh
yeah
well I'm going to win in spite of you
and because of you and then that's the
and that's why there are so few people
who have balls to be able to fight that
kind of resource in the face that's why
it's such a small percentage of people
that actually are dynamic people yeah we
spend a lot of time at the beginning
talking about finding the kernel finding
the truth finally the thing you should
go off and do and there's I think 95% of
America wakes up and drive to a job do
they hate and so finding the kernel is
the first part for some people who found
it though but don't believe in
themselves enough to chase it down what
do I do
believe in yourself and Jesus at that
whole thing about sensory I can't I can
do it the what source that can happen
you don't succeed right but if you don't
do anything you absolutely won't so
that's a like a lose-lose situation when
you don't try you know so I'm back it's
not gonna happen I know what I want but
it's never gonna happen
well that's a lose-lose there's no win
in that but if you try there's also the
opportunity for you to actually succeed
very well you might fail too but you
have now a better chance to get what you
wanted because you are actually chasing
after something in a proactive way now
the more work you put towards it the
more you stop saying I can't
and just do the more successful your
chances are you're going to be because
money is gravy should always be gravy
it's a perk which it people should
always go after is the other thing that
they really just want to express in
their lives really going after their
passion doesn't they love to do and
money just finds its way somehow I have
been on this planet for a long last time
and I know I'm one of the first people
that was the brother was self-loathing
self-destructive people you know well
they existed I took a lot of like all my
childhood abuse and my mother being like
mentally ill and and very physically
violent and they're verbally abusive and
everything was like she's never know
when things were gonna go flying and as
as horrible things were going to happen
and my father was such a workaholic that
he was never there good man but he was
never there and doing a job he hated
doing because he was trying to support a
family and so I did all kinds of
self-destructive things and so I didn't
believe in myself then I ended up having
a couple of moments of like I almost
died because incredibly bad
self-destructive behavior but I said I
can't do this anymore yeah I start
looking at life differently and seeing
it is something that I can grow from and
not beat myself up from anymore I want
to be an actor coming out to LA that's
where people get acting jobs what do I
need to do in this study so I went and
got an acting class I don't need to pay
for those classes I worked at Ralph's
and worked at a supermarket which I did
college and high school too I worked at
a gym record changer horrible jobs I
don't think anybody's gene will ever be
working in a supermarket
that's really a bad job but anyway the
did that to support that but it's okay
because I was supporting my a dream that
without me being an actor I never would
have gotten to be an acting teacher it's
that
to go with that flow was finally finding
its way by following the initial kernel
which is what that was and and and
working at the supermarket it was it was
a beautiful day when I could say I'm
making so much money acting and writing
I don't need to work here anymore but
the idea was that it was a necessary
thing and made by journey of being
successful that much more satisfying if
you have to work for it and you have to
do sucky jobs and you have to do things
that you really hate doing but doing it
to support and finance the dream that's
that makes your second climbing Mount
Everest it's like you get to the top you
might die you did something fall gonna
be an avalanche the air is different you
could not suffocate all kinds of things
could happen to you but would you get to
the top it's like oh kind of moment so
it's the same kind of thing if it was
too easy you didn't have to work for it
if you didn't have to fail and then
build yourself up again it wouldn't be
that the satisfying when on the other
side of things do you think you have to
hit rock bottom to climb to the top no I
don't think you hit rock bottom I think
you'd have to push the envelope so hard
that rock bottom could happen to get the
motivation and drive to get after it is
it I'm willing to take the chance and I
might hit rock bottom and you might
leave you don't have to it's just you
have to put yourself in that kind of
like forward motion see I want to work
so hard and take so many chances where
boundaries are meant to be crossed
pink boundaries out of like you know
your lexicon of things I can't do this
there's a boundary here I'm not supposed
to do this because don't have an
education for that or or I can't do this
because other people told me I can't do
this or I'm too old for this or too
young for this or whatever
take boundaries out of the thing out of
the lexicon of like things that you
follow and you just go like I'm gonna
push I'm gonna make choices that are so
push the envelope cutting-edge choices
I could hit bottom with this cuz that's
when great things happen it was a hard
for you to leave the troit and come here
was that hard for me to leave Detroit
and come here yeah it's always sunny in
Detroit
let's start there the weather a little
kick drawing up saying one day I'm gonna
live in Los Angeles where I don't have
to sit there with snow drifts around me
like this all the time I and also it
just doesn't have the environment that I
needed to have to do it I wanted to do
and I always wanted to be an actor since
I was like I don't know six seven years
old but finally at some point you say my
life has to change and let some dark
moments and out of that something I see
graduated from from college they said
this is your so you anthropologists and
all these things were talked about
before like behavioral science that was
just helped me a great deal but I didn't
need a degree in that right I took art
history classes I took the classes in
literature the sciences the arts the
filmmaking all kinds of things that I
took classes and just so I say knew I
was I was going to be in the arts and I
just needed to be well-rounded enough
someone if you're going to recreate real
humanity you have to understand all the
parts of it so instead of going to like
acting classes there I said okay I got
what the information I want so I got and
I got three and a half years in but I
didn't I kept changing my major so I
could just learned a lot about a lot
about you know every topic is that I'm
very informed now in different
characters and different scenarios
helped my script doctor for writers they
work with directors so I understand so
many things off of learning from that
point of view so I left there and it was
also during this time I really hit I hit
you know bottom and that and I said
listen let's just go I learned a lot in
school let's go to LA and like it's
let's be proactive
I'm thinking the just the emotional toll
of you
family you're going into uncertainty you
don't know what's gonna happen there you
don't have to take chances
yeah you have to take chances that are
cutting edge yeah if you play it safe
you get safe results you play from fear
you're fearful results if you play with
courage then you're gonna get dynamic
results and so you have to have the
courage to say I may fail you also have
the courage to go over that far away
it's an environment that by the way is
so extremely different to come from the
suburbs of Detroit they're coming to LA
you have no idea how many times I had
been people took advantage I'm like I
got him within two days I had someone
steal my car take back my money try to
take advantage you know sexually and it
was just and I said I'm not gonna give
up I'm not going back so I found a way
right my uncle wouldn't let me stay just
like he lives in Brentwood you wouldn't
let me stay there one night and so I
guess I what I did was I got my parents
to wire some money saving this really
crappy motel and I got a job at Ralph's
got a job a supermarket and and then was
able to get a tiny little apartment I
mean really tiny didn't have room first
stove or nothing it was just really tiny
barely could have a bed I'd like a
little colors those burners that a plate
yeah they just all basically is the one
little thing boil the coil yeah like a
Bunsen burner you know like for cooking
Bunsen burner you know and and so so
it's but I was willing to take the
chance that more stuff like that's gonna
happen and more stuff happen I got
married to a very abusive guy thinking
this is gonna keep my baby a safety net
net because I was scared is lonely and
talking to very foreign land
he spoke my language that was about it I
felt very like a person in a foreign
land that's why I married this guy
because I don't know I knew him two
weeks but it turned out to be one hell
of an abusive man and ultimately ended
up being very physical abuse at first it
was like very motion abusive and then it
became very physically abusive in the
hospital and so so lots of stuff
happened but I was not going to give up
I'm going to win in spite of and because
of and indeed what happened was I was
getting acting jobs because I was using
him as my substitution I was using him
and my writing to explore the passion of
wanting to get my power back
so it became dynamic because I was using
it to solve to solve and empower myself
to being a more powerful person one last
question
thank you for your time as you talked
about dynamic personalities for whatever
reason your daughter came into my head
and just trusting that energy if if
she's watching this back in ten years or
20 years and is going through mom's
archives of video footage and this old
YouTube video pops up and she's watching
this whole thing what he hoped that she
then learns about you or takes away from
it that she can reflect on for herself
interesting question cuz she's actually
seen every single one of those things
I've done she makes sure that she goes
like desktop a lot and just like
investigates what I'm up to because I'm
always writing something or working on
something she's feeding off of it I hope
that she uses me has because she's doing
this it has used me as a role model to
always be curious and to and she
respects me and looks up to me and she
wants to learn from me and that's
something that to me my mother because
she was so crazy and I don't know it's
part of the crazy so she's just not a
very smart woman but the point it's like
I didn't respect her because they have
to have her already doing this so we
don't need 10 or 20 years it's happening
as we speak she's one of the teachers of
my school she also runs the the youth
program and she's also making a film she
graduated with honors from Tisch and
filmmaking and may you and
she's constantly trying to learn and
grow and learn and grow and learn and
grow and her takeaway and what we're
talking about today has already been
taken away it's already there so for me
this would be if she were to look at
this in 10 20 years to say honey I'm so
proud of you you're a really amazing
person you're everything in more than
they thought you could be I love that
Ivana Chubbuck for people who want to
dive deeper into your world where do you
want them to go next but my book is a
really good resource I found that just
because the whole concept of taking a
character's journey and saying take the
pain and the hurt and the fear and
turning it into your ability to overcome
and win with is a great way to live life
and a lot of people all over the world
are using it as a self-help book to be
able to just say I'm gonna take my if it
works for a character is gonna work for
me so they're taking their lives and
they're using it for it for work for
their social you know for their love
relationships for their relationships
with their parents making them more
successful with their children whatever
and then just the book is a really
really good guide to be gotten and and
many many many languages great it's
called the power of the actor will link
it up in the description thank you for
your energy your advice your guidance to
wisdom I really appreciate it you're so
welcome
if you want to learn how to make it as
an actor check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there